Cuando en febrero de 2022, docenas
de tanques, helicópteros y soldados
rusos atravesaron la frontera ucraniana, los
dirigentes de la UE no solo entendieron que
los tambores de la guerra estaban sonando en
su propia puerta, sino también que su frágil
seguridad energética había desaparecido.
Sin embargo, el tiempo ha pasado y aunque
la guerra en Ucrania y las
sanciones a Rusia continúan,
hoy las cosas se ven de forma muy diferente.
N1 (21 de agosto de 2023: La UE alcanzará su
objetivo de almacenamiento de gas meses
antes de la fecha límite. Euronews)
(31 de agosto 2023: Suministro de gas a la UE:
Cuando Rusia entró en modo de autodestrucción. DW)
(11 octubre 2023:Europa se prepara
para la primera ola de frío a
prueba de sistemas energéticos. Bloomberg)
Queridos amigos, amigas, del terror energético
en Bruselas ya queda poco. Sí, Europa tiene
hoy una energía más cara y eso está afectando
a muchas industrias, pero pese a todo los peores
pronósticos no se han cumplido. En verano,
incluso, pudimos ver declaraciones como esta:
(18 de agosto de 2023: El almacenamiento de gas
de la UE ha alcanzado el 90%, mucho antes
de lo previsto. Esto nos ayudará a estar
seguros este invierno. Juntos estamos dejando
de depender del gas ruso. Y seguimos trabajando
en paralelo para diversificar el suministro
energético en el futuro. Ursula von der Leyen)
Claro que aún es pronto para cantar victoria.
(Si antes de la guerra, el gas ruso representaba
cerca del 40% del total importado por la UE, desde
entonces su peso ha disminuido a toda velocidad.
Ha sido mayormente sustituido por la masiva
importación de gas licuado (GNL) procedente EEUU
y algunos socios africanos. Algo que ha podido
mitigar la falta de gas este invierno, pero que
podría no ser del todo sostenible a largo plazo.)
Sí, para el invierno de 2024 se ha logrado
garantizar un stock suficiente de
gas; sin embargo, los dolores de
cabeza podrían haberse tan solo pospuesto.
Y es que veréis, en teoría, la UE podría
aumentar las entradas de gas natural licuado en
el corto pazo en unos 60 mil millones de metros
cúbicos respecto al promedio de 2021. Sin embargo,
el problema es que todo el mundo se está pelando
por este gas. Y no hablamos solo de Europa,
sino también de Asía. Hoy por hoy el mercado
de gas natural está tremendamente ajustado,
cualquier imprevisto podría disparar los precios.
Europa necesita nuevas fuentes de energía y
recursos naturales. Y lógicamente para lograr
nuevas fuentes hacen falta nuevos socios.
La pregunta es: ¿En quién se puede confiar
en un mundo cada vez más revuelto? ¿Un oriente
medio al rojo vivo? ¿Un sudeste asiático bajo
el acecho de China? ¿Un continente africano
dónde las guerras brotan por doquier? No se,
amigos, pero no parecen las mejores opciones del
mundo. No al menos las más seguras, ¿no os parece?
Pero… Un momento, ¿y qué ocurre
con América Latina? Pues…
N5 (15 de mayo de 2023: Venezuela
concreta un acuerdo con Repsol y Eni
para exportar gas a Europa. El País)
N6 (13 de junio de 2023: La UE apura
el acuerdo con el Mercosur y prometió más
inversiones en litio en Argentina. Cronista)
N7 (14 de junio de 2023: Chile y la Unión Europea
refuerzan vínculos en hidrógeno verde con miras
hacia un desarrollo sostenible. Minrel Chile)
N8 (3 de noviembre de 2023: Brasil registró
producción récord de petróleo y
gas en septiembre. AgenciaBrasil)
Queridos amigos, Latinoamérica no solo cuenta
con gigantescas reservas petroleras y gasíferas,
además de otros muchos, muchísimos
recursos naturales, sino que,
además, es una región donde los choques
armados siguen brillando por su ausencia…
Y precisamente por eso aquí en VisualPolitik
nos hemos hecho unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Puede ser Latam un socio fiable para lograr
la transición energética que se ha propuesto
Bruselas? ¿Qué países del cono sur pueden sostener
una relación estratégica con la UE? ¿Sería capaz
América Latina de sustituir a la mismísima Rusia?
Pues… Todo esto y más os lo contamos.
Gasolina y ¡Arranquemos!
[Pero antes, solo una pregunta, ¿te has parado a
pensar en lo que te estás perdiendo por no usar
el patrocinador del vídeo de hoy, Surfshark?
Lo primero de todo, y más importante, es
la seguridad en la red. Con Surfshark,
tu actividad online está fuertemente protegida,
cifrada y a salvo de ojos curiosos. Además,
con CleanWeb, te despides de los anuncios y
el malware. ¿Y qué pasa con los emails? Con
Surfshark Alert te enterarás al instante si
alguien ha intentado filtrar tu información.
Pero, ¡aún hay más! Surfshark es la
primera VPN comercial con servidores
en más de un centenar de países. Vamos,
algo así como un pasaporte global a golpe
de click: podrás acceder a cualquier
contenido bloqueado por ubicación.
Y si te preocupa tener que elegir en qué
dispositivo usarlo, tranquilo. Con la misma
cuenta, puedes proteger todos tus dispositivos, ya
sea tu móvil, tu tablet, la tele o el ordenador,
¡sin límites! Esto hace que puedas compartir la
cuenta con tus mejores amigos, por ejemplo. Así,
entre todos, cada uno pagaréis
unos pocos céntimos al mes.
Además por ser parte de la
comunidad VisualPolitik ESTE
MES podrás disfrutar de la OFERTA EXCLUSIVA
DE BLACKFRIDAY: SEIS MESES EXTRA totalmente
gratis si usáis el código “POLITIK”.
Os dejamos el link en la descripción
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos
con nuestro video de hoy!]
T1 (UNA RELACIÓN TÓXICA)
Amigos y amigas, conocéis ese
dicho que dice: “¿guerra avisada no mata
soldado? Pues si la respuesta es que sí,
¡sois afortunados! Porque todo apunta a que
precisamente en Bruselas no lo han oído nunca.
Poco a poco la relación entre Europa y Rusia se
fue convirtiendo en algo así como una relación
toxica, una relación en la que Europa se convirtió
en una parte de la relación tremendamente
dependiente. Esto quedó perfectamente claro
cuando en 2014 Moscú y Kyiv tuvieron su primera
enganchada tras la anexión rusa de Crimea.
(26 de marzo de 2014: Obama insta a la UE
a diversificar sus fuentes de energía para
acabar con la dependencia de Rusia. Politico)
(9 sep 2014: La dependencia europea del
gas ruso podría reducirse en un contexto
de eficiencia energética. The Guardian)
(17 de marzo de 2015: La vulnerabilidad
de Europa frente al gas ruso. Los Estados
miembros europeos tienen diferentes grados
de exposición a la interrupción de
los suministros procedentes de Rusia,
que deben abordarse para garantizar el
futuro de la Unión Energética de la UE. ECFR)
Sin embargo, en aquel momento, aunque la
desconfianza de Bruselas hacia el Kremlin existía,
esta no era tan grande. Al fin y al cabo,
¿cómo demonios iban los rusos a renunciar a
la tonelada de euros y dólares que cada año les
enviaban los países europeos? Una representante
clara de esta idea fue, precisamente, la
canciller alemana Angela Merkel. Fijaos.
C1 ("En la perspectiva de la época, era muy
racional y comprensible proveerse en gas de red,
inclusive de Rusia, que era menos caro que
el GNL (gas natural licuado) proveniente
de otras regiones del mundo". Angela Merkel)
("Inclusive durante la Guerra Fría, Rusia fue un
proveedor de energía confiable. No lamento para
nada las decisiones tomadas”. Angela Merkel)
En fin, lo hecho, pues hecho,
está, ¿Qué queréis que os diga?
Europa solo se tomó en serio el problema
de la dependencia rusa cuando el Kremlin
lanzó sus zarpas sobre Ucrania… Por
segunda vez. Eso sí, para ser justos,
hay que decir que desde el año 2014 algunos
equipos europeos han estado trabajando en
planes de contingencia en torno a la
importación masiva de gas licuado.
Algunas de esas iniciativas prediseñadas
dieron forma en mayo del 2020 a la estrategia
"REPowerEU”. Hablamos ni más ni menos que
del plan oficial de la UE para romper con
Rusia y reformular su matriz energética
por completo. Conforme a este plan,
a partir de ahora se seguirán 3 criterios
fundamentales en el viejo continente:
Ahorro energético
Sustitución de fuentes de energía
Y diversificación del origen
de las energías fósiles.
Las mayores inversiones en energía solar y
eólica, junto a la ampliación del uso del
carbón y la energía nuclear, hicieron que
durante los 6 primeros meses del 2023 se
registrara una importante caída en el consumo de
gas natural. El plan parece estar funcionando.
El problema es que esto es algo que
se ha logrado con energía más cara
y con un enorme desafío logístico que
podría fallar en cualquier momento.
Y justo aquí es donde de repente Latinoamérica
se ha colocado en el punto de mira de Bruselas:
desde el oro negro co n burbujas de la Venezuela
saudita, hasta el gas de vaca muerta en Argentina,
o el sorprendente caudal de reservas
petroleras que ha descubierto Brasil.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente Latam puede
acudir en auxilio de Europa? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
PETRÓLEO: UN TREN PERDIDO)
No os engaño si os decimos que Rusia no es un
proveedor nada pero que nada fácil de sustituir.
Sin embargo, las reservas de crudo de Rusia se
calculan en unos 107 mil millones de barriles
de crudo, frente a más de 320 mil que sumarían
México, Argentina, Colombia, Brasil y Venezuela.
Sin embargo, pese a tener más
petróleo, el rendimiento del
nuevo mundo es cuando menos decepcionante.
(Cómo podéis ver, solo Brasil ha logrado
incrementar con fuerza su producción en los
últimos años. Mientras tanto, Venezuela y México,
que entraron en el s. XXI como auténticos
titanes del petróleo, han ido de mal en peor,
al tiempo que la producción argentina
y colombiana ha permanecido estancada.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según estimaciones
del Energy Institute, estas cinco naciones
producían en 2003 cerca de 9,6 millones
de barriles diarios. Dos décadas después,
la suma apenas llega a 7 millones. Y no es porque
no tengan crudo, sino esencialmente porque los
diferentes gobiernos no han sido capaces de
explotarlo. Lo más curioso de todo es que
hace no tanto tiempo la producción petrolera de
América Latina era mucho mayor que la de Rusia.)
En Venezuela, ¿Qué os voy a contar? La revolución
bolivariana acabó de raíz con el sueño petrolero.
Y no lo hizo por convicción, sino básicamente por
incompetencia. En México pasó algo muy parecido,
la gestión de PEMEX ha sido un
desastre y en Colombia… Bueno,
aquí en VisualPolitik ya os contamos cómo Petro
quiere acabar de cuajo con esta industria.
De todos, solo Brasil parece haberse
tomado esta cuestión en serio. Y eso
que su producción se realiza sobre todo en
aguas superprofundas, lo que, lógicamente,
es mucho más complicado y mucho más caros.
N12 (1 de septiembre de 2023: El petróleo
presal brasileño gana una popularidad mundial sin
precedentes. Petrobras destinará 41.000
millones de dólares de inversión para
aumentar la producción de petróleo en
un 19% de aquí a 2027. WorldEnergyTrade)
Y eso no es todo.
Ya no es que América Latina tenga problemas
para extraer su petróleo, es que tampoco han
logrado desarrollar una capacidad razonable
de refino, que es el proceso que hace falta
para lograr que el oro negro con burbujas
se convierta en combustible. Salvo Brasil,
la capacidad del resto de la región permanece
anclada en los niveles de los años 80. De locos.
Todo esto es lo que explica que
pese a tener muchos recursos no
sea raro ver noticias como estas:
N13 (10 de enero de 2019: La alarma
por la escasez de combustible se
extiende a Ciudad de México. ElPaís)
N14 (22 de junio de 2023: La
escasez de gasolina en Venezuela,
una crisis convertida en rutina. InfoBae)
N15 (13 de octubre de 2023: La escasez de
nafta se hace sentir en el comienzo
del fin de semana largo. Clarin)
El problema es que la capacidad de refino
de Europa ha seguido un camino muy similar.
¡A nadie le gusta tener sucias y
feas refinerías cerca de casa!
En otras palabras, que toda esta falta de
inversión hace que a corto plazo la capacidad
de América Latina para sustituir a Rusia como
proveedor predilecto de Europa es limitada.
Pero si por ahora el crudo latinoamericano
no parece la opción definitiva… ¿Qué
ocurre con el gas? Pues… Atentos.
T3 (LA SOLUCIÓN DEL GAS LATINO)
No es un secreto que si hablamos de gas, Rusia
es todo un campeón mundial coloso. Con más de 40
billones de metros cúbicos de reservas probadas,
el gas de Rusia es cinco veces más grande que el
gas conocido de América Latina. Sin embargo,
aquí la industria latina se ha comportado
mucho mejor que la petrolera y, además, el
fracking podría llegar a obrar milagros.
Eso sí, tenemos que volver a
mirar caso por caso. Por ejemplo,
en Brasil el gas natural tiene un uso industrial
muy importante. Sin embargo, siguen tirando gas.
Sí, sí, me habéis oído bien, tirando
gas, quemándolo innecesariamente por
falta, sobre todo de infraestructuras.
Luego, por otro lado, México es uno de los países
mejor situados. Su sector gasífero está altamente
desarrollado, pero tiene una característica
dominante: su interdependencia con EE. UU.
México exporta gas natural a EEUU, pero también
lo importa para aprovechar los bajos costos de
procesamiento de su vecino norteamericano. Esto
ha impulsado la construcción y finalización de
enormes redes de gasoductos en todo el país.
N16 (4 de octubre de 2020: Red
de gasoductos “Wahalajara” ya
opera en su totalidad. El Economista)
N17 (3 de mayo de 2023: Pacific Limited
invertirá 14.000 millones de dólares
en un gasoducto en México. Expansión)
N18 (12 de octubre de 2023: Estados Unidos
cerrará 2023 con exportaciones récord de
gas natural gracias a México. Forbes)
En cuanto a la Argentina, entre 2005
y 2015 el país gaucho se quedó atrás
por culpa del agotamiento de los pozos
convencionales. Los Argentinos llegaron
incluso a tener que importar gas pese a
contar con Vaca Muerta, una de las reservas
de gas potencialmente más grandes del mundo.
Por fortuna eso está cambiando, y de
hecho en julio de 2023, se inauguró el
gasoducto Presidente Néstor Kirchner”, que les
permitirá desde 2024 volver a exportar gas.
En Bolivia, sin embargo, no
parecen de enhorabuena:
N19 (1 de septiembre de 2023: El Gobierno
boliviano admitió que se acabó el gas:
para 2029 el país deberá importarlo. InfoBae. El
presidente Luis Arce dijo que las reservas se han
agotado y que las exportaciones a Argentina
y Brasil deben interrumpirse, lo que deja un
enorme hueco en la economía del país)
Finalmente, Venezuela es el único país
que ha registrado en los últimos años una
importante en sus niveles de producción.
De todas formas, al igual que ocurre con el
petróleo, las buenas intenciones no bastan.
Tener reservas o, incluso, niveles de
producción relevantes no basta. Hace
falta también tener la infraestructura
necesaria para poder exportar el gas.
Pues bien, aquí los latinos también
van muy por detrás de los rusos.
Por supuesto, no solo hace falta
gasoductos. Para poder exportar el
gas hasta Europa hacen también falta plantas
de licuefacción. Esto es, instalaciones que
permitan convertir el gas en líquido para poder
transportarle en grandes barcos metaneros.
Latinoamérica necesitará de muchas inversiones
y varios años para hacer esto posible. Eso sí,
a la larga podría encajar con las necesidades
europeas. Sin embargo, estamos todavía muy
lejos de que esto fuese algo relevante. A corto
plazo ni el gas mexicano, ni los hidrocarbonos
de Vaca Muerta o de alta mar de Brasil podrán
sustituir a Rusia en el mix energético de Europa.
Pero entonces, la pregunta es, ¿En qué solución
están pensando en Bruselas? Sin socios posibles,
¿Qué podemos esperar a partir de 2025
para la matriz energética del viejo
continente? ¿La seguridad energética
europea se fue para no volver?
Pues atentos.
T4 (HIDRÓGENO…
¿LA RESPUESTA ESTÁ DENT RO DE EUROPA?)
Queridos amigos de VPK, ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando… Seguro, seguro que en Bruselas cuentan
con que las renovables sean la solución a todo,
¿verdad? No podemos culparos, en las últimas
décadas el optimismo sobre la energía solar
y la energía eólica ha sido enorme. Y
lo cierto es que hoy su rol es clave.
La capacidad de las renovables europeas se ha
incrementado un 1500% en los últimos 20 años.
Desde luego ha sido un proceso clave para que
Europa no se quedara a oscuras tras el apagón
de los gasoductos rusos.
Sin embargo, pese a ello,
la nueva esperanza de Bruselas parece estar en un
combustible, pero uno no fósil. Estamos hablando,
por supuesto, del Hidrógeno.
(La generación de energía a base
de hidrógeno es posible cuando en una pila
de combustible, el hidrógeno se introduce,
por un lado, y el oxígeno por el otro.
En el lado del hidrógeno, los protones se
separan y crean una corriente eléctrica. Los
electrones liberados generan electricidad y,
en el lado del oxígeno, se combinan con los
protones y forman agua como único subproducto.)
Y no, tranquilos, no es que nos queramos poner,
lo que ocurre es que necesitamos entender cómo
se produce electricidad con el hidrógeno para
entender una realidad clave: su deslocalización.
El proceso no está sujeto a ninguna
reserva, yacimiento o insumo que esté
atado a una realidad geográfica. Y de
hecho, ahí radica su enorme potencial:
el hidrógeno podría llegar a garantizarle
a Europa la autosuficiencia energética.
(Como es lógico, lo único que sí hace falta en
este proceso, es el hidrógeno. Pero este puede
obtenerse de diferentes formas. Por ejemplo,
se conoce como hidrógeno gris a aquel producido
mediante fuentes de energía de origen
fósil como gas natural, el petróleo,
o el carbón… Mientras el hidrógeno verde, es
el producido a partir de fuentes de energía
renovables y con bajas o nulas emisiones
contaminantes asociadas al proceso)
¿Pero qué diferencia al hidrógeno de la
energía eólica o solar? Pues básicamente que
es almacenable. El Hidrógeno se puede almacenar
y utilizar cuando sea necesario, por ejemplo,
como combustible o para generar electricidad.
Para muchos esto resolvería el gran problema que
tienen las energías renovables convencionales: la
intermitencia y la irregularidad. Incluso, Europa
podría llegar a exportar este combustible limpio.
Claro que esta opción también despierta
muchas dudas sobre su eficiencia.
Muchos expertos argumentan que nunca
será un proceso eficiente y que además
hace falta una infraestructura adecuada
que llevaría tiempo y dinero construir. Sea como
sea, el Hidrógeno está en los planes de Bruselas
y ya hay muchas inversiones contempladas
para desarrollar esa fuente de energía.
C2 (“Afortunadamente, la infraestructura
de gas natural existente puede actuar como
catalizador para ampliar el transporte
de hidrógeno. A corto y medio plazo,
la mezcla de hidrógeno con gas natural puede
facilitar el desarrollo inicial del comercio,
mientras que la reutilización de gasoductos puede
reducir significativamente el coste de establecer
redes nacionales y regionales de hidrógeno.”[JR1]
Global Hydrogen Review 2021 – IEA)
En septiembre del 2022, Austria, Bélgica,
Dinamarca, Finlandia, Francia, Grecia, Italia,
Países Bajos, Polonia, Portugal, Eslovaquia,
España y Suecia suscribieron el proyecto “IPCEI
Hy2Use”, el cual contempla hast a 5.200 millones
de euros en financiación pública y 7.000 millones
de euros adicionales en inversiones privadas.
Por otro lado, en marzo de 2023 la UE anunció
la creación del Banco Europeo del Hidrógeno, el
cual se encargaría de mitigar la diferencia de
costes entre el hidrógeno renovable
y los combustibles fósiles para los
primeros proyectos operativos del continente.
¿El resultado? Cómo podéis ver en este mapa,
Europa es la región con más
proyectos de Hidrógeno del mundo.
Queridos amigos y amigas, hoy es imposible
saber si finalmente será el hidrogeno,
el gas natural licuado o incluso los suministros
de América Latina los que den forma a la nueva
matriz energética de Europa. Las oportunidades
y los problemas están sobre la mesa.
Lo único seguro es que Europa nunca más
será dependiente del gas y el petróleo
ruso. América Latina vuelve a tener
una gran oportunidad para encontrar
una enorme fuente de inversiones y dólares.
¿La aprovechará? Solo el tiempo podrá decirlo.
Por ahora la pregunta es para ti:
¿Qué papel crees que jugará el
hidrógeno en la seguridad energética de
Europa? ¿Podrá América Latina aprovechar
esta oportunidad para lograr un
enorme río de dólares y euros?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios. [Y
ahora, si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
este canal si es que aún no lo habéis hecho
Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” este mes podréis disfrutar de SEIS
meses extra totalmente gratis con Surfshark.
El link, como siempre, en la descripción.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima